chantal hébert parloir ce que l'on
retrouve bonsoir paul hélène buzzati
bonsoir bonsoir ça on va écouter
monsieur duclos qui a été très clair cet
après midi chantal vous en parlait hier
au panel d'écouter la nonchalance pas
une bonne idée mais je vous explique
pourquoi ce sujet allait peut-être vous
pourrez pour venir ça va être compliqué
on écoute monsieur du cloud et en
revient
toutes les provinces doivent accélérer
leur processus de vaccination de
troisième dose avec les informations que
l'on a maintenant qu'on avait pas
irakienne à peine quelques semaines on
s'aperçoit qu'une troisième dose est
absolument essentiel pour protéger
contre l'infection et contre le risque
de maladie c'est l'air et donc le risque
d'hospitalisation alors c'est ce qu'on
va devoir faire c'est la priorité
première pour toutes les provinces y
compris pas de québec n'ont augmenté
considérablement le rythme des
vaccinations nous avons présentement au
rythme des vaccinations au pays qui est
à peu près le cas de ce qu'il était
durant l'été encore en israël étaient
jeunes en juillet-août ont vacciné
quatre fois plus de gens par jour je
pense qu'on a besoin d'arriver assez
rapidement à ce rythme à nouveau
vous aurez compris que cet extrait il
l'a été aussi clair qu'à ce que je sais
mais c'est pas sûr le voyage le voyage
ils voyageaient pas d'extrait cette
troisième dose il y avait deux messages
ottawa voyagez pas et la troisième dose
messieurs dames des provinces accélérer
le rythme chantal hébert on craint
il le dit d'ailleurs
s'assombrit il faut de redoubler de
prudence et de rapidité plus rapide
j'entends way et ça tombe bien que vous
ayez passé cet extrait là plutôt que
celui sur les voyages parce que la
priorité franchement c'est pas les
voyages est une des choses que le
premier c'est-à-dire justin trudeau ya
soir quand on ya parlé aux premiers
ministres des provinces c'est ouais
c'est que personne n'ose s'opposer à ce
qu'on dise aux gens de moins voyagé mais
si on leur dit moins voyagé et qu'on
dise pas d'autre chose c'est parce que
les parents sont aussi dit si vous
voulez qu'on est des mains pour mettre
des ce règne dans les bras
comptez pas sur nous pour aller faire
des tests dans les aéroports paul donc
insistance lourde sur l'accélération la
troisième dose on viens de l'entendre
lumineuse qui dit on vous on aimerait
revoir le reste de cet été
oui et
on verra bien si c'est possible je sais
depuis quelques quelques jours de
m'inscrire pour avoir ma troisième dose
abois
malheureusement je ne serai
éligibles que le 24 décembre ça tombe
mal mais a donné de ma troisième dose
ici en ontario c'est carrément
impossible
on verra si ça s'améliore au fil des
prochaines jours
et on ne sait où on est toujours assez
loin de la certitude sur la question de
ce à quoi on fait face est ce que c'est
quelque chose de vraiment néfaste et
dangereux parce que c'est quelque chose
de si
anodin que que c'est ce serait quasiment
mieux d'attraper le hall au micro que de
l'inviter on ne sait pas encore et mais
par excès de prudence je pense que la
réponse
des provinces et du fédéral
est ce qu'il faut si tant est qu'on peut
faire ce qu'on ce qu'on essaie de faire
et là je suis loin d'être certaine sur
ces questions de logistique des mots
n'est pas médecin personne mais docteur
croître question mathématique oui ça
peut être anodin pour 90% des gens ici
le 10 % il y en a trois pour cent qui se
rendait à l'hôpital la capacité du métal
hier on y revient tout le temps hélène
c'était la possession depuis le début de
cette crise que ça sa paume des
ressources et ça on le voit quand même
ça monte plus rapidement les
hospitalisations en ontario sein des
impôts jour d'hui mon québec ça moi je
suis évidemment promettre un merci de
fait rappeler mais je l'écouté aussi
docteur quoi chez et quand même il faut
apporter une légèrement ci semble que
clairement cette troisième dose elle
soit très efficace pour éviter les
hospitalisations et particulièrement les
décès chez les personnes plus âgées je
pense par exemple en israël où on a fait
deux corps en fait des 50 ans et plus on
a regardé ce qui avait reçu deux doses
versus vers ceux qui avaient reçu trois
doses et pour ces gens alors le tour de
décès avaient diminué de 90% avec la
troisième dose dont clairement pour les
personnes plus âgées c'est très efficace
troisième dose c'est moins clair pour
les personnes plus jeunes est ce que
vraiment la priorité doit être
absolument de donner une troisième dose
plus vite pour les personnes de 18 ou 20
et à la science en poète absolument
transparentes claires clair clair encore
là dessus et j'ai trouvé un peu bête le
calcul un peu mathématiques de monsieur
du clos d'hier bas cet été on faisait
quatre fois plus d'un vaccin
qu'aujourd'hui la wii mais cet été on
vaccinait tout le monde est ce que c'est
vraiment la priorité à faire à ce moment
de vacciner même les plus jeunes quand
même la question se pose parce que
beaucoup de gens vivent beaucoup de gens
avec des blouses blanches commencent à
dire que on est mieux on est beaucoup à
protéger
en ontario ses 18 ans je le rappelle
paul dit oui mais dans les faits il
manque de monde ou si comme au québec
bon vacciner 1 chantal
bon la bonne nouvelle popol c'est qu'ils
étaient le gym maintenant parce
qu'aujourd'hui on en a eu aussi trois
mois plus tôt que six
la mauvaise nouvelle pour paul c'est
qu'on a aussi dit tout le monde peut
s'inscrire et là on voit
le même le même pattern qu'on a vu avec
le gouvernement fédéral qui disent on va
fermer les frontières mais pose est au
smic c'est à dire c'est une chose de
dire et c'est une autre chose d'exécuter
et c'est déjà difficile en ontario pour
quelqu'un qui à 50 ans ou plus de
trouver un rendez vous après six mois
alors vendredi quand tout le monde 18
ans et plus soit pouvoir s'inscrire
bonne chance ce temps des fêtes les gens
qui donnent ces vaccins comme les autres
vont faire une pause c'est un peu léger
effectivement de dire et en plus on a
mis beaucoup d'énergie dans toutes les
provinces thaksin et des enfants c'est
un peu léger de dire ah ben oui mais là
il faudrait revenir au garage
[Musique]
fédéral pas réussi à prouver qu'ils
étaient capables de faire quoi que ce
soit défi qu'a sur le test des gens
frontière même en excluant les gens qui
avaient des états unis non mais
je le jure chantal sous l'ère un très
bon point est le fait de d'ouvrir sa à
tous va peut-être faire en sorte que les
personnes pour qui cette troisième d'eau
serait la plus efficace c'est à dire les
personnes plus âgées de se tromper que
les premières à se faire vacciner alors
cyrus quand même le danger de vouloir
aller trouver en ouvrant toutes grandes
ouvertes les portes à tout le monde tout
de suite
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont posé des
questions je me suis dit claude jean
trouvez vous pas que le québec devrait
revenir avec le vin
avec moi quand j'ai fait l'entrevue de
docteur couach qui dit là faut sortir de
cette logique d'un exactement combien de
personnes il faut entrer dans une
logique de responsabilisation et de pas
avoir une multitude de contacts
différents 4 5 jours ça peut presque
être pire chatel parce que je regardais
ce matin je me suis amusé les premières
pages les journaux peu partout c'est
rare les gens qui parlent que de 20 15
les santé publique en occident dit le
moins possible
ouais et mais ça ça veut dire aussi que
le ministre santé celui du québec ou
d'ailleurs et le premier ministre se
promène pas en disant c'est qu'avec un
parti ya ben parce que ça envoie
vraiment pas le bon message sérieusement
là on le voit en ligne puis on l'entend
ses collègues avant et
ya pas vraiment de balises là dedans
aujourd'hui le gouvernement de l'alberta
a annoncé non seulement chi chi chi chi
le libéraliser ces mesures mais qu'en
plus les non-vaccinés pouvait se réunir
avec les bac 6 me pour noël alors si
vous pensez que les gens sont mêlés
machine y recevoir ses messages le pôle
en ontario pour ce débat-là de combien
de gens à l'intérieur de chacune des
maisons oui parce que eux on n'a pas de
chiffres on a seulement les consignes il
faut faire le gars il faut faire
attention si on dit d'une part comme
comme comme on dit au québec d'une part
on dit responsabilisation d'autre part
on divin responsabilisation ses sept
syllabes ben c'est une célèbre c'est
beaucoup plus facile à retenir voilà il
s'inquiète toutefois de confusion parce
que l'on devient on fait de la chimie et
de l'alchimie
bon
c'est reparti de plus belle on en a
parlé quelques jours la loi 21 le débat
sur la loi 21 ans est reparti de plus
belle votre
votre collègue chroniqueur dans le globe
chantal ce matin je ne pouvais pas aller
plus loin éditorial cinglant on ne peut
plus mesurée mais quand même le fond est
le même là je vous fait écouter
d'ailleurs je vous montre avant bas
bruit parce que vous allez mieux
comprendre les changes à la chambre des
communes babri ambassadeur du canada à
l'onu qui a écrit cette loi est
profondément discriminatoire il va à
l'encontre de la déclaration universelle
des droits de l'homme dont ambassadeur
canada et ça a donné cet échange à la
chambre des communes
est ce que le premier ministre euh parce
que c'est de toute évidence ce qu'il
convient de faire rappeler l'ambassadeur
li immédiatement je suis en profond
désaccord avec la loi 21 je trouve pas
que dans une société libre quelqu'un de
vrai père sa job à cause de sa religion
nous allons continuer d'être du côté des
québécois qui eux mêmes sont choqués et
déçus que fatim ans anne-marie et perdu
son emploi à cause de sa religion et
nous appuyons hinault sur suivant les
québécois qui eux défendent leurs droits
en cours devant cette loi qu'ils
trouvent et jusque le premier ménès
cautionne une diffamation contre une loi
est une nation tout aussi légitime que
ses prétentions à lui nous défendons au
québec la liberté de religion c'est pour
sow qui a tellement de québécois qui
sont surpris et déçu de voir la jeune
fatima à anne-marie enseignante perdre
son emploi parce qu'elle est musulmane
on a comme libéré la parole la campagne
est passé et l'inde buzzati là mais ce
truc 12 et entre on a l'impression comme
j'ai moi qu'il se sent plus à l'aise de
dalea au fond de sa pensée mais je sais
pas par rapport à ça c'est sûr qu'il y
parle de manière plus volubile parce
qu'en campagne électorale c'était pas
très vendeur de les taper sur la loi 21
au québec là où on voulait faire des
gains mais quand même la position
monsieur trudeau elle n'a jamais changé
je suis un drogué hauteur il a toujours
été contre en fait moi j'ai un petit peu
tiqué aujourd'hui quand il a même le dit
quelque chose comme est ce qu'on demande
aux juges et aux prises et policiers de
quelle religion ils sont juste pas
certain de comprendre comment
interpréter cette déclaration mais est
ce que ça veut dire qu'il ne s'est pas
qu'au québec la loi 21 interdit aussi
aux policiers aux juges de porter un
symbole religieux mais moi je ne trouve
pas qu'il a changé radicalement punition
ça me fait un peu rigoler du côté du
bloc québécois parce que c'est quelque
chose qui revient souvent on avait dit
ça je pense en 2019 en vo on sait bien
il va attendre après l'élection de mai
19 pour contester la loi 21 à présent
nous ont remis le même disque à l'aller
à l'élection 2021 pardon 2019 et le
maintenant on nous dit ah ben on va
attendre élections québécoises et après
celle de 2022 l'on va contester je pense
que fondamentalement c'est qu'ottawa ne
voit pas nécessairement qu'est ce qu'il
pourrait apporter de plus dans une
contestation judiciaire que ne le font
déjà les gens qui contestent cette loi
21 et c'est pour ça qu'ils s'aimaient
pas il ya eu
beaucoup d'articles depuis ça s'est
sorti publiquement jeudi soir dernier
l'exemple de cette enseignante qui est
des êtres tassé compte tenu de son voile
il ya plusieurs années quand on sent là
vraiment que il ya beaucoup de gens qui
disent c'est le moment de s'exprimer
contre cette loi là qu'on juge injuste
paul oui et on voit par ailleurs des
d4 venant des sages québécois qui nous
disent nous du reste du canada de me
taire parce que
tactiquement stratégiquement c'est pas
c'est pas bien de d'inciter les
québécois comme ça j'ai vu un article de
l'ancien sénateur en série élite ardu de
la presse andré pratte dans assure
l'auteur il ya quelques heures qui
disait après cela mais
les gens qu'il soit au québec ou hors
québec ne sont pas très tenté par les
calcul tacticien
ils vont s'exprimer sur cette question
comme sur tant d'autres questions
sans vraiment penser à l'effet tactique
que ça peut avoir
est
maintenant si justin trudeau a changé de
discours depuis quelques jours
c'est vrai qu'il jouait sur les deux
registres depuis toutes deux ans il
était pas forcément d'accord avec la loi
mais pour l'instant il faisait rien mais
éventuellement il pouvait faire quelque
chose là il sans rage dans une chambre
des communes contre l'injustice c'est
parce qu'il sent la pression venant de
ses députés des députés de l'opposition
d'après tout ce qui a une opinion sur
ces questions là et les gens n'ont pas
vraiment le goût de 7 depuis quelques
jours oui chantal aygat il faut dire un
changement non seulement de ton monsieur
singh a changé d'attitude en temps il
faut qu'on participe à la contestation
donc là encore changement comment vous
voyez ce débat se réinstaller
je suis d'accord avec paul j'ai eu
l'impression en écoutant justin trudeau
aujourd'hui qui parlait d'abord à son
caucus où une grande partie de son
caucus et c'est pas parce qu'on dit plus
fort quand on dit quelque chose de
différent dans ce que s'il dit la même
chose et lun raison qu'ils avaient
toujours dit sauf qu'il le dit plus fort
dans le cas de bob reeves
je comprends totalement ce qu'ils
essaient de dire mais néanmoins il était
à l'extérieur de son devoir de réserve
c'est pas le rôle d'un ambassadeur qui
représente le canada aux nations unies
de faire la leçon à une province ou à
une autre c'est un autre rôle s'ils
veulent d'abord il peut et il ya le
droit à ses opinions mais là dessus il
était à côté de sacoches et d'autre part
et finalement j'ai l'impression moi que
ça fait la sphère finances françois
legault à la veille d'une campagne
électorale qu'il n'avait de boucliers à
ce sujet la dent de cette façon là qui
vient de l'extérieur du québec et comme
je vais parler de mon collègue de hâter
chou sans dire ce qui avait recommandé
un bloco une nuit dit que le merlan du
canada devrait retirer des transferts
pour la santé ou autres au québec
jusqu'à ce que la loi 21 disparaissent
et je peux faire une prédiction il ya
aucun chef des oies qui va en partie
dedans mais jusqu'où où se déplacera le
débat devant les tribunaux on le sait
que ça va aller jusqu'en cour suprême
mais comment le débat va se dessiner au
canada dans les prochains mois est ce
que ça va c'est un sursaut parce qu'il
ya eu un exemple vous croyez que ça va
se retirer paul
c'est déjà un peu plus grand que jeudi
et vendredi on a appris que
l'enseignante à chelsea n'a pas perdu
d'emplois elle va animer un atelier 2
deux d'entre eux médiatisation et
d'écriture sur des thèmes de la
diversité elle devient en quelque sorte
le symbole de
de la résistance antilles et haloua 21
au sein même du québec
s'est elle a l'air va trouver
goethe achats c'est assez intéressant
mais la loi 21 s'en va à la cour suprême
du canada à trous sur je sais
pertinemment que les justes de la cour
suprême la tombe et et
les chefs des partis et politique aussi
et tout le monde a juste son discours en
fonction de cette quasi s'appliquer
voilà il a tout le monde à jeux sont
faux et je dirai où la chef libéral au
québec oui qui marche sur des oeufs là
tu me le dis je suis contre la loi mehdi
lallaoui
celui qui a vraiment le plus changé
d'opinion c'est vraiment monsieur singh
qui pendant la campagne oui c'est vrai
voulait pas dire qu'ils allaient
conteste participants de contestation
maintenant qu'il a vu qu'il n'a plus
aucun succès et de potentiel de succès
au québec le unique comme comme les
autres qui veulent participer le plus
coincé note que c'est évidemment
monsieur o toole parce que il y a des
recteurs et les conservateurs qui sont
d'accord avec la loi de dieu merci à
vous trois retouches avoir retrouvé par
le chanteur elana très bientôt tout le
monde merci beaucoup à boire autre pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici r d